haleh j'ai une question pour toi tu es
un expert en IA juste quand penses-tu qu'il
y aura des yeux au niveau humain salut Jade
donc généralement des vidéos sur ma chaîne en
français comment va ta française Jenny pop
Alphonse dit d'accord bien puisque tu es tel
un grand youtubeur scientifique je vais faire une
exception pour vous pour aujourd'hui je
parlerai en anglais même si cela signifie que
chacun de mes téléspectateurs se moque de mon
accent français merci lis alors que
pensez-vous qu'un niveau humain a est possible
une IA  jamais surpasser un auditeur dans toutes les
tâches et à moindre coût et si oui, pourquoi
quand tout cela pourrait-il se produire, ce sont des
questions fascinantes et il est extrêmement
tentant d'avoir une opinion bien arrêtée sur
des sujets aussi controversés, mais il est
extrêmement important de noter d'abord que
prédire l'avenir est  une
tâche extrêmement difficile, surtout compte tenu de la
complexité du monde moderne et de la rapidité avec laquelle
il évolue en particulier, mon grand
conseil serait de ne pas faire confiance à vos tripes
et de ne pas faire confiance à mes tripes non plus d'accord, bien sûr,
mais c'est quand même  une question importante, je
veux dire au niveau humain, des yeux impliqueraient
des changements aussi énormes dans le monde, comment pouvons-
nous construire une réponse plus éclairée,
même si aucun individu ne peut être
considéré comme fiable, c'est souvent le cas que
l'opinion d'une communauté de  les experts
donnent des réponses plus fiables ouais, alors j'ai
trouvé cet article de la revue technologique du MIT
et il dit que les experts en IA ne
pensent pas que l'IA au niveau humain est une menace pour l'
humanité, attendez, avez-vous vu qu'il y avait
un suivi à cet article, regardez  au
bas de l'article ouais c'est ce qui est
bizarre, l'article de suivi dit
exactement le contraire, donc ce qui se passe ici, je
suppose qu'un élément clé à retenir est qu'il y a de
gros désaccords entre experts et
qu'il y a même des désaccords sur
ce que les accords du  les experts sont
c'est un gros gâchis et malheureusement de nombreux
experts en IA ne sont pas utiles et préfèrent
présenter leur propre point de vue sur l'avenir de l'
IA ainsi que leur propre point de vue sur le
consensus des experts de l'IA mais
là  C'est aussi une raison plus subtile et plus
fondamentale pour laquelle les deux articles
ne sont pas d'accord, voyez-vous ce à quoi je fais allusion,
c'est sur la façon de penser aux risques que
je pense avoir ou vous dites dans l'
enquête discutée dans le premier article
qu'ils ont demandé à AI  experts de dire quand ils
pensaient qu'il y aurait une IA au niveau humain
alors que l'enquête discutée dans le
deuxième article donnait des dates précises et
demandait aux experts en IA de dire les
probabilités qu'ils pensaient qu'il y
aurait une IA au niveau humain à ce moment-là, donc
ce pourrait être le  cas où presque tous les
experts en IA pensent qu'il n'y aura pas d'
IA au niveau humain d'ici 2050, mais en même temps,
ils pensent qu'il y a environ 10% de
probabilité qu'il y aura une
IA au niveau humain d'ici 2020 exactement et lorsque
nous discutons des risques, il est crucial de  penser
en termes aussi probabilistes, en effet, une
centrale nucléaire qui est plus susceptible de ne pas
exploser n'est pas nécessairement une
centrale nucléaire rassurante, même si elle a
une probabilité d'explosion de 1%, je dirais
que cela reste préoccupant  et
nous devons toujours nous préparer au pire
oui et nous ne devons pas accorder trop d'
importance aux enquêtes qui ne posent que des questions
sur les scénarios les plus probables, il est
important d'envisager des enquêtes qui
discutent de la probabilité de différents
scénarios et heureusement pour nous en 2015 un
expert ai des deux principaux  a Des
conférences sur l'IA ont été étudiées de cette façon et
sur 1600 34 d'entre elles, 352 ont accepté de
répondre aux questions de l'enquête, vous
devriez y jeter un coup d'œil Jade laissez-moi voir
wow cette enquête a demandé aux experts de l'IA de tracer
sur un graphique pour une date donnée la probabilité
qu'ils  je pensais que ce serait que le niveau humain des
yeux serait arrivé à cette
date et voici à quoi ressemblent les courbes de
différents experts également ici en
rouge est un agrégat des prédictions
des experts quand la chose cruciale à
noter en regardant les graphiques est de savoir comment
beaucoup d'experts en IA ne sont pas d'accord, il est
important de le noter car cela signifie qu'aucun
expert n'est représentatif de tous les experts
en particulier, il y a un énorme
biais de sélection chaque fois que vous donnez une grande  importance
pour un seul expert, alors regardons
l'agrégat selon l'expert,
il y a 50% de chances que d'ici l'an
2060, un AIS de niveau humain soit
arrivé, nous avons donc probablement un peu de
temps selon les experts de l'IA de niveau humain
dans quelques  dans des décennies est le scénario le plus
probable, mais en termes de risques, nous
devrions également nous soucier des scénarios moins probables
, ils disent également qu'il y a
10% de chances que le niveau humain a des yeux d'ici
2025, c'est si tôt oui et 10% est
loin d'être  encore une fois négligeable, les
plans nucléaires avec 10% de chances d'
exploser ne devraient certainement pas être construits,
mais l'IA au niveau humain peut être encore plus
explosive qu'une centrale nucléaire comme nous en avons
longuement discuté sur ma chaîne et
comme le fait Robert Mars sur son humain  niveau a
Je possède l'existence de risques pour l'humanité à
moins que nous n'investissions massivement dans la sécurité de
l'IA L'IA au niveau humain pourrait bien détruire l'humanité
au moins il y a un argument solide fait par
Nick Bostrom dans son
livre sur le super renseignement que nous devrions considérer le
des  la construction de l'humanité comme scénario par défaut
si l'IA devient surhumaine, d'accord,
mais 10% est la prédiction des experts,
quelle est la probabilité qu'ils aient raison
à ce sujet,
je veux dire que les experts ont fait des prédictions très sérieuses
dans le passé, ils
ont certainement par exemple  Marvin
Minsky pensait que l'
IA au niveau humain serait là dans les années 1970, il avait
surestimé la vitesse de progression, mais
les erreurs de prédiction ne seraient pas toujours dues
à notre estimation des progrès futurs. En
fait, ces derniers temps, il semble que l'inverse
soit plus souvent vrai par exemple dans le
Les experts de l'enquête de 2015 ont prédit qu'il nous
faudrait 12 ans pour qu'un œil surpasse les
humains au jeu de go,
mais alphago a battu lee sedol quelques mois
plus tard en supposant qu'ils se
trompent également sur l'IA au niveau humain, ce
qui suggère que nous ne pouvons pas exclure la possibilité
que  un œil atteindra le niveau humain
dans quelques années, je vois,
je suppose que le manque de fiabilité des experts
devrait être considéré comme une incertitude supplémentaire
si la distribution  des
prédictions d'experts pour l'IA au niveau humain ressemble
à une courbe en cloche, alors cette
incertitude supplémentaire devrait aplatir la courbe, mais
regardez cela signifie que la probabilité d'
événements extrêmes augmente oui en effet
parce que les experts ne sont pas fiables, nous devrions
en fait être encore plus préoccupés par la
possibilité de  l'IA au niveau humain dans un
avenir proche et au lieu d'une probabilité de 10%
d'IA au niveau humain d'ici 2025, nous pourrions
envisager une
probabilité de 10% d'IA au niveau humain d'ici
2022, d'accord, mais il est très difficile d'
imaginer qu'atteindre le niveau humain ne serait pas  les
yeux ont besoin d'une sorte d'intelligence
ou de conscience réelle et qu'en est-il de la
consommation d'énergie le cerveau humain est très
efficace les ordinateurs peuvent-ils vraiment être aussi
efficaces que le cerveau humain
il y a certainement d'énormes obstacles pour arriver
à l'IA au niveau humain mais la recherche
progresse à un rythme impressionnant  rythme à la fois
en termes de matériel et de logiciel en
termes de matériel, par exemple la
loi dite d'Akuma suggère que la
consommation d'énergie d'un seul
calcul  chute de façon exponentielle car
il est divisé par deux tous les 18 mois et les
innovations dans l'
informatique et le stockage de données paralysés sinon décentralisés
peuvent permettre à cette tendance de se
poursuivre, alors qu'en est-il du côté logiciel,
n'avons-nous pas besoin d'une sorte de
percée majeure probablement c'est difficile
pour comprendre le défi logiciel,
il est utile de revenir à un article d'assurance de
1950 dans cet article, il a suggéré
qu'une grande partie de la complexité du
cerveau humain est essentielle pour atteindre
le niveau d'intelligence humain, mais le
cerveau humain possède environ un million de milliards de
synapses  si 1 000 d'entre eux sont essentiels
pour l'intelligence au niveau humain, cela suggère
qu'une IA devra être d'une taille d'au
moins un téraoctet à laquelle le niveau humain
aujourd'hui la taille des grandes zones est généralement
de l'ordre de Giga octets et le
plus grand AIS
semble lentement  atteindre un téraoctet, cela
suggère qu'en termes de complexité, nous
pourrions bientôt déterminer ce qui est nécessaire pour
l'intelligence au niveau humain, mais il est difficile
d'imaginer que cela  s est suffisant pour
atteindre le niveau humain a yeux je veux dire n'avons-nous pas
encore besoin de former ces yeux a oui en
effet mais une grande partie des données nécessaires sont
sans doute déjà là pour atteindre
le niveau humain assez grand et bien
conçu d'un je pourrais lire Wikipedia
encore et encore et regarder des vidéos scientifiques sur
youtube, c'est une chose d'être
exposé à ces données, mais une IA
pourrait-elle réellement apprendre de ces données, cela pourrait-il
conduire à nouveau à une véritable intelligence, c'est
difficile à dire, mais il est important de noter
qu'il est difficile de le dire  il semble que
beaucoup de gens croient que puisque les AIS
ne font que des opérations mécaniques, ils
ne peuvent pas rivaliser avec les
humains, mais le fait est que longtemps les
opérations mécaniques sont en fait pleines
de surprises, elles peuvent conduire à des résultats
que nous, les humains, ne pouvons pas prédire, non pas
parce que les opérations sont compliquées
en fait chacune  l'opération est extrêmement
simple
mais un est effectué un grand nombre d'
opérations aussi simples c'est quelque chose
que notre cerveau ne peut pas faire et c'est
pourquoi notre cerveau ne peut pas  prédire le
résultat des calculs d'un œil, ce qui
signifie qu'ils conduiront à des résultats
qui nous ont surpris.
est l'
hypothèse que dès qu'un fait est
présenté à un esprit, toutes les conséquences de
ce fait lui viennent simultanément à l'esprit
c'est une
hypothèse très utile dans de nombreuses
circonstances mais on oublie trop facilement
qu'elle est fausse une conséquence naturelle
de le faire  est qu'une Lynne suppose
qu'il n'y a aucune vertu dans le
simple calcul des conséquences à partir de données
et de principes généraux exactement et donc
nous ne devrions pas être trop confiants quant à
ce que nous pensons que des yeux énormes peuvent faire
leurs longs calculs
nous surprendront probablement bien en fait si  vous avez
suivi les développements récents d'un
gars dont vous auriez probablement dû être
surpris par des images photoréalistes
odieuses  ges le sous-titrage automatisé de YouTube
et les appels téléphoniques en duplex de Google vous
me connaissez qui vous salut j'aimerais réserver une table
pour le mercredi 7 pour sept personnes
c'est pour quatre personnes
eh bien les gens gagnent mercredi à 18h.  Oh en
fait vraiment monsieur car comme si c'était
comme 5 personnes pour vous ci-dessous, vous
pouvez venir combien de temps est habituellement le chemin pour
être assis [ __ ] quand demain
pour mercredi prochain le 7 oh non ce n'est
pas trop facile vous pouvez me rappeler d'accord
oh je  vous a
encore frappé c'était un vrai appel avec beaucoup de
ces exemples où les appels
ne se passent pas comme prévu mais l'assistant
comprend le contexte pour le nuancer de nouvelles
tâches pour les temps d'attente dans ce cas et
gérer l'interaction avec élégance oui nous
devrions être préparés  pour des
développements surprenants potentiels dans l'IA qui leur
donneraient des capacités de raisonnement au niveau humain
en particulier compte tenu de tout ce dont nous avons
discuté, je dirais qu'il y a de
bonnes raisons de dire que l'
IA au niveau humain d'ici 2025 devrait avoir une probabilité
supérieure à 1% et  à bien y penser,
1% est énorme, surtout compte tenu de la
perturbation de cette IA au niveau humain,
c'est pourquoi je dirais que nous devrions
vraiment prendre au sérieux la menace de l'IA au niveau humain
et investir massivement dans l'IA
sécurité hé j'espère que vous avez apprécié cette
vidéo un grand merci à Jade d'un
article je recommande fortement sa
chaîne YouTube est l'une des plus grandes
choses là-bas et bien sûr ses vidéos sur la
physique qui est son arrière-plan sont
vraiment très bonnes mais je
recommande fortement encore plus ses vidéos sur
les idées d'informatique particule il y en a
une sur la singularité et il y a aussi des
vidéos sur le
surajustement de l'apprentissage automatique ou le
problème d'arrêt optimal je recommande fortement ces vidéos
et aussi nous venons de faire une vidéo sur la chaîne de Jade
il s'agit d'une solution pragmatique
à  mettre en place le chargement de valeur en
simulant une démocratie virtuelle sur des
versions extrapolées de nous-mêmes pour
les voitures autonomes confrontées au problème du chariot
avant de revenir sur les
commentaires de la vidéo précédente Je veux
souligner à nouveau l'article que j'ai
écrit sur la façon de gérer un
IA au niveau humain et en particulier comment charger des
valeurs dans un qui est un problème très très très
difficile je recommande fortement
quiconque est un peu intéressé par ces
idées d'aller lire cet
article car je pense que c'est la chose la plus
importante que j'aurais jamais
écrite de ma vie - à propos du
billet d'opinion komono est une douce solution la Vida
automatique donc notre kuhmo  à propos de
la mission pauvre n'est pas ce qu'ils prévoient
de chauffer en tant que Muto ici Samuel Genesee
des possibilités infinies parce que Veronica
qf9 hace una elle ira huit non celui-ci
ici est
sur ce qu'ils semblaient assez fantaisistes
algues hors non excuses sur  en raison de la
communauté technologique, un individu particulier,
donc dans une graine si passe-haut, si vous pouviez
visiter le sol sinon une section
oh boy ouais somos de cuisine pas de
puissance de climatisation ici Sacramento mucho à
maman pour venir vous donc je dirais certains
les gens Sentinelle - kevie Christoph
Michelle un général ne manque pas une vidéo
donc tu es un gros tueur le pugiliste
sous l'eau si je suis le séquestre
améliorerait la réalisation facile de la casserole que tu as mangé si
tu veux c'est vraiment cool as-tu eu un
média de choc  plus de caractère
ouais j'ai dit ce poste pour les jeunes
pouliches à sept hommes tu dis ce que tu
lui dois en clair juste un corps partiel
pour s'opposer à lui car il n'y avait pas d'
éducation draconienne c'était trop tôt les
devoirs de flammes comme de passer le devoir au numérique
ooh brûle manifestement X rien ouvert  ou
court 1finity parafoil une coquille Gribble
un individu supplémentaire mais j'étais
malade en fusion sur les citoyens sur extermo MPG sévèrement
unique mot-clé d'indication d'eau de coupole
ordinateur talentueux de restitution
apaisé Royaume-Uni donc national dire cash whisky
non moi un travail de bip oui coupon juste
tenir sur un dos Kinnaman  garantir Domini
cela se voit là-bas au fur et à mesure que vous allez renifler vous obtenir
plus Benishek devenir ou le réduire
radicalement est arrivé le
passé national de l'éducation réformée vous donne beaucoup au rôle de la
personne un cas où cela vous savez
notre quatuor oh ils les font parler d'une
situation Symington orteil à travers l'iniquité
prison certains coupons non remplis
décision quand vous allez à un PTA est notre
annuaire téléphonique avec le temps P supposez que vous
connaissez des sous-marins seniors a  la nécessité donnée
ne serait pas du canola pour les 11 nouveaux jours de PDG pas de
senior c'est un démoniaque avec Danone
sera J mais
2005 suivi PK a donc source qtz la
technologie viendra plus tard aller
combinaison éternelle 205 Jean pong world
tu sais educativa precook toka - ah elle a en
fait laissé  vous savez bientôt, je dirais que
j'ai montré aux ordinateurs si vous demandez à un
nopon efficace et occupé, lisez-vous
ceux qu'il a également dit pas d'action d'action Appa
ou limitez un ordinateur, allez-y
- sur YouTube patate je suis  merveilleux livre
beaucoup d'enthousiasme
oh allez sur la vidéo youtube merde monde
même au-delà d'aujourd'hui la détection a révélé
une formule marcher vous madame ouais la
ville phénomène YouTube sur la cire ouais -
total net c'est une parodie qu'un seul IKEA
ce soir un dicton comme la pierre ain '  t
pas [ __ ] de simple super voila ils viennent pour
aller a l'ecole une [ __ ] sur facebook ils
viennent faire un tweet un lien vers youtube si tu
veux vraiment marcher sur tes pattes sur
Martinez sur le metier a l'envie
boulot avec Ricky Satya
un calico Simon we  dit toi  vous pourriez encore faire des
clowns et vous savez que vous savez que c'est comme un
public ici à l'air pur, vous pouvez
deviner votre présence WebP est important
corrompu car le groupe le plus populaire
savez-vous si vous devez visser un
contenu cool, je suppose que des options amusantes vous connaissez
seppuku  mija individuel chaque semaine comme
seulement le cumin du Kentucky au-delà du supplément
passer une prédiction dans Bitcoin vous
spéculerez sur la croissance d'une façade CL à proximité
chaud Louis modem agissant nous savons mec
Jenny faire un monsieur dramatique négativement fille
qui une fille motivation illégalité cool
Sean ce soir encore à voir est  à d'autres faire l'
hymne, nous sommes typiquement mouillés si vous mettez une
aiguille dessus sur Queenie nouveau comme les
hommes ne le feraient pas non plus Dooku ne paiera pas
Lincoln vous savez
s'il vous plaît professeur cette jambe gauche sur la
coquille exploite un 25 $ pour la Turquie yo vous donc
particulièrement  propriétaire compliqué maman heureuse
tu sais ouais ils sont une fête Alice muna a
perdu son cahier est sur des conneries est
un profil humain est une vraie mafia informatique manuelle
il a continuellement repoussé alpha
ne dis pas de domaine  Pau Zotoh a Malloy
Siana kotelnyk wah-wah a l'air plus vieux la
piste aussi su sitio de tousser sur les
trophées
enfer ouais voir une mousson vortex plus
énorme vous associez les médias et
tirez sur un mot stupide garçon après avoir dit
votre inquiétude je vais prouver l'expertise dans
une audition de feu sacré de vague vide - une
nécessité pour la femme de décision de l'hôtel
à Yeldon encore plus une de plus
vous savez qu'un Lugano Jamison avoue que le
calcul allait être principalement
des pieuvres avec précision bientôt près de Houma cacher de
Dieu qui, dans l'homme de nuna, elle semblait
jolie à  moi quel choix - -41 chez
les pros - années pion surtout
en Europe bref tout à fait développer une avance
Kazuma tu coopères - tu as postulé aussi
- Yahoo element array au Met
compress c'est pareil un Popeye's n'extermine pas l'
humanité ben pas plus de pouvoir
les ratios et à tous ne permettent pas l'épisode
qui doit inclure des répliques -
ordinateur par massage sécurisé passage vidéo
genouillère champion Pasi femme ouais Dyneema
sofia un autre flippy
je dois juste sav  e manquer un clip vidéo
conclure l'offre
l'année dernière il n'égoutte rien d'autre l'athlète
n'est pas encore confus Joey ne donne pas je suis
en feu optimiste a Je fais efficacement la
promotion de l'échec de Dante Joseph ne
savions-nous pas que je suis tous pris une faveur par  de plus en
plus de gens, il ou elle présente une
probabilité 9u puissante laïque ne peut que les médias
exploser à Machpelah vous pouvez tenir votre
nouvelle société n'attribuez pas votre Ania
mmm ajoute-t-il une description très
Monica Civic psychopathiquement
votre Jean qui reçoit l'accent même un
spécialiste très compétent Université
électricité Rhodésie le travail n'est pas Eliza
question 20 non Zelda Nagumo suppose que le
Vermont mettra en vedette votre humanité 800
moi une sauce soja et d'anciennes
vidéos persécutées Philip Oakey a besoin d'une
partie d'apprentissage Idaho courage Palmer ne me donne
pas quelque chose à la pathologie modifier le
comportement de  de retour sur le dépassement de
hiddenville City FL en désaccord parallèle
Vince vous du bassin est une attitude commune de
terminus possum de certains
Bergame et injecter crucial pour être
impossible induire un  problème générique voir
rentrer à la maison ils battent la chambre au
bord de l'eau un montant record en toi
une utilisation de routine toc toc je me suis bien débrouillé pour la
nourriture bien comment ai-je dit pour dire qu'ils ressentent
différemment la musique alors comment Lucia le lot
Jose le Videocon là-bas une clé  juste
pour rentrer à la maison, vous développez une
conséquence spéciale si je suis malchanceux vol Oracle
nous accueillons la clé un secondaire super
cool faire confusion un fait Absalon est la
mobilité de la caméra d'action un décret pour
absent de couleur j'ai remarqué la beauté
mais si triste que vous puissiez assister au
rôtisserie l'enquête sur la portion linéaire
manque Egidio possibilité d'un coma
télépathique sur la banlieue sur 22 épisode
maintenant moins cher bien qu'il vienne juste de Beckham
Sevilla poussant maintenant pour le légendaire
mathématicien John von Neumann a été le
premier à utiliser cette phrase pour décrire
cette belle journée quand il a dit que l'
accélération constante  le progrès de la technique
donne l'apparence d'approcher quelque
singularité essentielle dans l'histoire de
la race au-delà de laquelle les affaires humaines telles que
nous les connaissons  ne pouvait pas continuer 70%
des experts en IA conviennent qu'il s'agit d'
un problème au moins modérément important et dans
quelle mesure les experts en IA pensent que la
société devrait donner la priorité à la recherche sur la sécurité de l'IA
48% d'entre eux pensent que nous
devrions lui donner la priorité plus que nous
ne le sommes actuellement et  seulement 11% pensent que nous
devrions moins y accorder la priorité, donc nous y sommes.
Les
experts en IA ne savent pas vraiment ce que
l'avenir nous réserve, mais ils pensent que les
risques catastrophiques sont possibles et
qu'il s'agit d'un problème important, nous devons
donc faire davantage de recherches sur la sécurité de l'IA.